le bac maintenant coup d'envoi demain
pour des centaines de milliers de
lycéens avec l'épreuve de la philosophie
et cette question qui revient avec plus
d'insistance encore cette année comment
lutter contre la triche les antisèches
sont passés de mode désormais ce sont
les téléphones portables et les mp3
qu'il faut surveiller reportage julien
pelletier
violaine vermot go il y avait les
antisèches au fond de la trousse ou plus
difficiles les théorèmes dont le stylo
dans la panoplie du tricheur voici le
téléphone portable
dernier jour de cours pour ces terminal
devant leur lycée tous sont un téléphone
entre les mains et certains l'utilisent
pendant les contrôles pour chercher
cours et corrigé sur internet google on
tape le nom du sujet ou de l'exercice et
c'est bon à prendre la côte sur google
il ya toi tu te mets au fond de la
classe et tous ordres
c'est pas compliqué je ne la trouve
comme ça le téléphone juste derrière
comme ça je regarde ta claqua que je
note
j'aurai les éléments les plus importants
et c'est dans la poche cette jeune fille
a même installé une application
spécialement pour tricher elle a
photographié des dizaines de courts
comme ça mais pas question de l'utiliser
demain le bac c'est trop sérieux
les fraudeurs risquent même plus gros
jusqu'à cinq ans d'interdiction de
passer le bac
seuls deux cents dix neuf candidats sur
600 milles ont été accusé de triche en
272 en 2010 même si la fraude est
marginal la hausse est là et elle est en
grande partie lié au nouveau téléphone
et a voulu déposer tout voit sa queue
devant un bureau
les téléphones portables sont interdits
à l'examen c'est comme ça le portable
doit être rangée or la triche existe car
les candidats ne sont pas fouillés et
peuvent quitter la salle pour aller aux
toilettes
ce prof de maths et surveillants au bac
et comme ses collègues il se sent démuni
face au téléphone à part la solution du
brouillage des centres d'examen je vois
guère autre chose j'envoie dire autre
chose surtout s'il ya encore une
continuité dans ces réductions de ses
outils de plus en plus petit des montres
des mollahs qui ont accès à internet à
quelques rares exceptions dans les
prisons ou les salles de spectacle le
brouillage des ondes est interdit par la
loi
la solution est peut-être ailleurs
depuis quelques années les épreuves
demande moins de parker et plus de
réflexion et la téléphone et internet ne
servent plus à rien voilà la solution
c'est aussi de ne pas souhaiter tricher
peut-être
[Musique]